hi I'm Lana and welcome to my channel I
was one of a lucky bunch of people who
got to play sub Punk 2077 for four hours
last week was so good and today I'm
going to do what I call a gameplay talk
through where basically because I wasn't
allowed to record gameplay I am instead
going to walk you through everything
that I did verbally I took a lot of
notes there are conveniently a bunch of
things that I did do that there is
footage um so for those pots we will
jump to the gameplay footage that CD
Projekt RED has released and in some of
those instances I can tell you how what
I did is different to what you're seeing
in the gameplay footage which i think is
one of the best parts of this game and
there's a hell of a lot of choice but
first a disclosure I'm just gonna make
it every time I ever talk about this
game just owning the fact that I'm very
biased where this is concerned I'm
extremely excited it's super high so
started with the character created okay
you know what I can actually take it
back even further started with a loading
screen cool thing about loading screens
I guess they are all videos of night
city that are rendered in real time
meaning that if you're seeing a building
or a crosswalk or whatever else in any
particular loading screen that is what
is actually happening in the world at
that given time pretty cool then we get
to the character customization which
yeah is super extensive we got to choose
between gnome and street kid and COPO
for the purposes of this demo I went
with Street kid which I did this
specifically because I asked the dev who
was there for me to ask questions to
during my play time I think I asked what
had other people done the leash dog so I
could have the most unique experience
and that led me to the street kid pop
they'll give you different backstories
obviously and it doesn't give you like a
fixed paw because going forward in the
game it's so much of an RPG that you can
very much customize your parks and your
skill sets regardless but it will give
you a different dialogue options
throughout the course of the game and
you can really only do things that the
character with that backstory would do
so then when we get to body and
appearance I wrote this stuff down there
are six skin types throughout 35
hairstyles seventeen eyes eight eyebrows
seventeen mounds seventeen jewels
seventeen is eight bits of cyberware
which are basically like lines on your
face plus you can have no cyber web
nine types of skulls six types of
tattoos eleven piercings five types of
teeth which I thought was nuts
okay customize your teeth Wow eight
different kinds of eye makeup five
different kinds of lip makeup three
different blemishes three types of
nipples or no nipples five types of body
tattoos two body scars there are two
dick types being circumcised and
uncircumcised and only one vagina type
which I feel is kind of Obama feel like
this should be more variety in vaginas
but it's fine there are also dick sizes
and chest size which I imagine is breast
size but both of those were disabled so
I could not play around so yes fair
amount of depth in that character
created it was very easy to make a very
good-looking character which is what I
always want and I could have spent a lot
more time in there than I did but you
know I only had four hours with the game
so I have to keep on going the other
thing you start with in the character
greater screen oh five skills which is
body intelligence reflexes technical
ability and cool they all started with
three and we could add seven points but
kid only maxes out and went out to six I
went with technical ability and body
which the dev I think was mostly
referring to as a solo build meaning
that I could get through stuff by myself
but also had some cool hacking stuff
going on as well I think I did some
reflexes too but I think that that ended
up being less important than I expected
because as you play on you can get
pretty crazy with those as as you love a
lot basically so when we start out in a
bar in a district called Heywood I'm
talking to a guy named Pepe who I
believe was in some kind of debt and
needed some kind of help I'm gonna be
honest I did not pay that much attention
to the opening dialogue interaction
because I was so caught up and looking
at the bar but that's the important
context so you need Pepe needs help and
there is a man upstairs who I can go and
talk to so I get my freedom and that's
one thing that I really loved about this
game it sounds really strange to explain
but the player agency of you finish a
conversation by saying press X to stand
up like show that prompt is on screen
and it's really the only thing you can
do but it means that you're never locked
in really any gameplay cinematics really
ever it's not like the game forces you
to stand up you still get to press X to
do that and playing through something
that does that for four hours just
really stood out to me and really
impressed me
they didn't take control away from me
so I press X to stand up and look around
the ball it's it's pretty neon I believe
it's like a pool table in the corner
it's pretty rundown you'd think that
this is not a super rich neighborhood
it's div' is what I would say it's
dive-bomb two storeys and I kind of walk
around and I think I end up going to the
bathroom just to kind of check out
what's happening in that there's a man
peeing and a soul who the dev told me
we'll have a dialog line if you stare at
him while he's peeing but otherwise
there was a guy just standing in the
bathroom on his phone so I just sort of
walked up to him instead at him for a
bit and you know just nice touch of
detail he ended up staring back at me
which I feel like NPCs and games don't
do that much of he just said something
generic to me like hey oh whatever
but but did notice that I was all up in
his business staring at him so I walk
upstairs I see the guy that I'm supposed
to talk to you but I continue to
basically walk around if you look out
the window everything that you see
outside is rented in real time and it's
particularly cool because you will see
you know cars driving and NPCs on the
street walking around so if I would walk
outside of the bar there would be no
loading screen those characters would be
there that's consistent through the
whole game very cool
so I take a seat in front of guy I'm
supposed to be talking to cook I believe
his name was again to start that
dialogue interaction that conversation
you hit X to sit and then I have control
over the camera the whole time
I can look wherever I want while I'm
talking to cook he tells me about a very
cool car that he would like stolen he
hands me a magazine and shows me some
information and I believe this was the
point where one of the cause in that
magazine was named after Garrett's sword
which was a cool touch I actually am
expecting some kind of crossover with
the witch universe more than just kind
of what's been floated other that we'll
see so he is like okay I'll help out
Pepe with his debt I think it is if you
go steal this coffin me should be really
easy what are you worried about but at
one point during that conversation a big
guy sits down next me and cheese bugga
so I can look at him and I can ask him
what he wants if I want to or I could
just completely ignore him but I was
definitely better intimidate me so cut
gives me some kind of chip and says you
know on your way this will unlock the
car when you get there bring me the car
so
go on my merry way ahead out of the ball
stop walking down the street it's
sparsely populated not terribly
populated it's pretty late at night not
too many people around but also again in
kind of a dodgy neighborhood is what I
would think I do pause two guys who are
having a conversation about the current
election that's taking place in night
city at the time there's a kind of a
little law dump that I could pick up
from the table to find out more
information about that too but then I
pass a homeless guy who's pretending to
be a veteran I know he's pretending
because he makes a comment along the
lines of oh you're a veteran today huh
and he says yeah it works he asks for
money I decided to give him money didn't
need to obviously I could have just kept
walking I wasn't locked into anything
and when the wireless transfer happens
his eyes go blue and I'm like holding my
wrist out to him blue eyes is how you
indicate a wireless transfer which I
really like just cool that you know that
that has happened even though it doesn't
tell you that's what's happening cash
does still exist though - so I'm walking
down this alleyway and I get stopped by
these two guys that car's parked and
they are pretty clearly waiting for me
one of them is Padre very much has the
vibes of a mob boss he's a fixer and the
two kind of politely told me to get into
that car I had the option to keep
walking around night city if I wanted
but eventually I would have to return to
that call I like the way this happened
it was really organic it was like I just
happened to stumble across him and he
was waiting for me rather than again
everything being directed by cutscenes
so I get in the car and he's talking to
be I can't recall exactly what the
conversation was sadly I think it was
about me walking for him in the future
I remember if I remember correctly there
were definitely pieces about how he had
gone to Atlanta and then decided to come
back and how that didn't work out but
yeah the whole time even though I'm
sitting in the back of a car I can still
look at whatever I want I can not even
respond to some of the dialogue things
that he says is a timer for some things
don't have to reply or of course I can
choose the options that will continue
the conversation so there are basically
like different colors to indicate this
will just give you more information this
will lead you to the end of this
conversation like an option that
finishes the quest or is heading in the
direction of finishing the quest and one
that's just going to give you more info
that you can ask over and over again so
while we're driving another
car pulls up beside us on the road
there's a guy with a gun in the seat and
they basically bully us into pulling
over
Padre doesn't actually seem that worried
to be fed so we pull over a guy gets out
of his car and he is a member of the 6th
Street gang he comes over and he
threatens Padre with his gun in the car
the two are in a turf war I suppose is
the issue and this guy has this really
weirdly smooth face like intentionally
just really smooth about it I don't know
that I saw any other members of the 6th
Street gang but it looked like he was
made a trouble so he's like kind of
bullying Padre whatever there is also a
part of this way I have the option to
tell this guy to back off or I think
maybe even tell Padre to calm down I
chose not to say anything the dev told
me that that would have repercussions
which I believe was in that instance
just a little bit of dialogue that would
show up later so Padre drops me off and
I'm conveniently close to my parking
garage where the car that I need to Jack
is I go in I talk to a guy in the booth
who Kirk told me would be there I could
have walked past him I suppose but I did
talk to him and he turns off all the
cameras for me for a few minutes I go
towards the car used the the unlock
thing the Kirk gave me and then the
scene with Jackie happens this one do
take for a world
[Music]
rich now fire her up and call me when
you're underway tell you where to go hmm
looks like this would be a cool breeze
get the [ __ ] out okay easy
nothing personal go back just biz ray
fields mine what man never heard of
thieves honor
Finders Keepers I was first listen only
one of two ways to do this friendly or
[ __ ] up
either way the endings the same I'm
taking the car what what are you doing
don't you godless you're under arrest
that's what I can see them nice and slow
Jackie wells my old pal from the hood
see you haven't grown an ounce wiser
hey detective stitch in a while uh
inspectors this same [ __ ]
speaking of your mugs familiar - yeah
using to me left for Atlanta looking for
a slice of happiness guess you didn't
find it I've always maintained it's the
same for all you termites in Haywood
born here live here died here looks like
I was right you know
[ __ ] about me truth hurts huh
just watch your tone I'm not a patient
man come on stitch give us a break huh
you lock us up I just jerk off till
trial and then what worst case we get
some months standing-room-only nowadays
another birthday so I probably out early
are these the thieves for generous free
trash got him in custody mr. Fujioka
will be taking them now it's a waste of
effort
I have no time to testify or play at an
investigation suggesting we let him go
sir I suggest you toss them in the sea
cuff legs broken so this trash doesn't
float
you heard him [ __ ]
and that only happens if he plays the
street kid I believe everyone will meet
Jackie in a different way depending on
the pot that they took and I'm actually
going to have a sort of another
discussion alive stream with some other
media folks in the industry
where we're going to talk about how
different our experiences well because
we played as different classes and had
different playthroughs so I wanted to
get those people together to like
actually talk about how different things
were based on the choices we made and
based on the path we chose so that
should be live on the first it'll be
7:00 p.m. Pacific time Wednesday if you
want to catch that but I'll leave the
stream up off to woods anyway okay so
the thing happens with the clouds so we
flash-forward to Jackie and I just kind
of waking up on the street and I guess
having a kind of nice conversation
deciding we liked each other and we'd
like to work together Jackie is so
immediately endearing and likable so
after that I think Jackie and I walked
to his car
I don't remember the exact sequence I'm
sorry but it did lead to him giving me a
militant cludes via training that has
basically been hacked
so if Millett X is one of the mega
corporations that focus on me obviously
a military-style attitude this chip that
you plug into would give you a training
simulation that has been unlocks to have
different kinds of training for people
in my position all these positions and
it's funny one thing that hasn't been
hacked is that it includes all of this
like anti corporation propaganda for
their main competitor which I just
thought was cool I love the I love how
dedicated they are to the lore of this
world they are not shying away from it
at all it rules so this is basically
when they give you a tutorial which is
pretty far in actually and is done in a
way that I consider to be creative you
get stealth tutorials and hacking
tutorials the hacking tutorial is a
little more complicated
it's definitely watchdog style in a lot
of ways you can blow up an explosive in
someone's pocket you can make someone
else's buzzer go off so that someone
walks towards them but there's also kind
of an in hacking currency that means you
do have to put thought into which of the
things you're going to hack and in what
order basically I didn't do a ton of
hacking actually but was definitely
satisfied with how complicated it
presented itself to be so stealth pretty
general sneaked up behind someone take
them out from behind there's also an
animation where you can take them out
and hide them at the same time if you
happen to be next to say a bin or
something I'll trash you can lift up a
lid and throw them in there throw their
bodies in there
but this is also where you learn about
things like weapons way when you sought
out with a certain weapon you're a
rookie so it will be a little bit harder
to control and will get easier to
control as you go on you will have less
weapon sway foster aiming these are all
things you can also manually upgrade in
your perks but the idea is weapon
specialization so say you favor a pistol
you'll get better with the pistol at a
time you can get better with a rifle
over time a better shot going about it's
my per rifle or whatever else this leads
into the start of the original gameplay
walkthrough that we saw where you walk
through the building to get the girl out
of the tub and then you leave her on the
side that played out pretty much the
same I used a lot more stealth options
than was seen in that gameplay footage
one thing that I found particularly cool
was just Jackie's AI was really
impressive he actually would take
control of situations he was clearly
following my lead and as soon as I
screwed up and broke my stealth because
I did he very much tanked his way
through and helped me out
which is really nice to see in games
were a lot of companion AI is kind of
useless and dumb and I feel like that
ruins the emotion a bit so it's not like
he's stealing all yet kills in a way
that's annoying it just made it feel
more like he was a real character and
this was a real situation I will say I
did explore a lot of that particular
building as much as I could and it was
very linear
there was one whole way that I got to
the end of and it was just kind of
inexplicably very black and had a lot of
bags in it which is clearly like telling
me I couldn't go any further that way
definitely very Linea structured mission
which is kind of how this world exists
but no loading screen to get into it but
yes that situation played out virtually
exactly the same as in the gameplay demo
that weasel so from here I believe
Jackie drops me hung we've already seen
plenty of bits of pieces of these
complex but one thing that impressed me
here was even in the elevator from the
parking garage to my apartment there's
actually like scripted TV shows running
like a late-night talk show just it's
this game was never born there is so
much interesting stuff to look at all
the time it rules so I went to these
apartment she's supposed to live in a
very cheap area but I will say her
apartment is bigger than mine I think
you can sit down and watch TV you can
take a shower
there is a closet with a bunch of
jackets in it I did try to change
clothes but wasn't able to there is also
a door that leads to a kind of workshop
area where you can do crafting basically
but that was disabled for the purposes
of this demo and then there's a bit
which is when I went to sleep which is
the only time that I had a loading
screen aside from the initial one in my
entire four hours playing had a loading
screen for me to sleep and wake up so
wake up head out seeing a lot more of a
complex at this point which again is is
definitely full of really cool
advertising it's just I mean I never got
bored of looking at this stuff in the
four hours that I played I hope I never
get sick of it the world is it's just so
much detail it's just not so much to
look at but I will say here is also
where I saw some NPCs who aren't
necessarily doing anything there were
two NPCs who believe was sitting in
playing chess but they were both
actually stuck in the exact same
animation as one another at the exact
same time oh maybe there were groups of
NPCs who were just kind of looking at
nothing not necessarily living their
lives but it's made to feel populated
and they all look very very different I
did see some repeated character models
more so when I went outside and it was
actually most specifically children that
they were repeated but yes they're also
plenty of things for me to interact with
that I did not interact with for example
boxing training coach you just really
wanted to get me in the ring is not
dissimilar to a particular Witcher 3
questline even a fable one quest line
didn't do it kept moving it went to the
weapons store this is where I found that
there are some weapons clothing and this
cyber where that was locked behind
street-cred there was a gun available
for me I didn't buy it because I think I
bought like new shoes or something
instead and yeah it is pretty strange
that you can customize the way you look
so much and I didn't see my own
character even once
that is strange but yeah plenty of stuff
to buy I had absolutely no money I got
the impression from some of the
questions that I asked the developer
that you will by the end of game as in
any RPG be super rich and not have many
problems with there was a katana in
there that I really wanted that was both
too expensive and required more street
cred I guess for anyone who doesn't know
as
already heard about this street cred is
kind of like an another system like
we're now well you can get things based
on literally how much street credibility
you have for how many people on the
street know you how Coolio perceived to
be which I imagine we'll just level up
pretty organically as as you play
through the story so from here I went to
ground level back down the elevator but
then instead of continuing immediately
on the main quest I went and did a side
quest those came up on the map is just
like a little blue icons generally very
little detail of what they are just sort
of a blue icon with a question mark if I
remember correctly I chose it was
actually the closest one and walked
there because I wanted to walk around
Knight city and get a feel for it during
the day definitely a lot of people
definitely a lot of cool stuff to look
at did see again repeated character
models which was largely in relation to
children and that is when I walked
towards the icon that turned out to be
Jesse Cox youtuber I think he's just
called Jesse and again jesse has
tampered with some kind of penis
enlargement or something I believe and
his dick is on fire and he wants you to
take him to a rip you talk cyberpunk
ladies and gentlemen so I stole a car in
order to do that I shot two people
inside of the nearest car in the face I
couldn't pull them out of the car like
GTA so I shot them in the face got in
the car got Jesse in the car drove him
to the Waypoint which was a ripper dock
I did occasionally hit a couple of other
cars I think I hit a pedestrian or two
cops didn't come after me at any point
and when I was talking to the dev team
about that they said you know they
wanted to make sure it was fun so they
did have to weigh up how persistent cops
would be there are other people who've
played the game who said that they just
ran over like two pedestrians and the
cops did come but my guess is that they
were in eyesight so honestly don't know
how prevalent cops punishing you for
crime is going to be at this point it
probably varies depending on what
neighborhood you're in or you know what
kind of crime you've committed so I
dropped Jesse at the ripa dock he needed
to go to and he actually did call me a
little bit later on the phone and
thanked me and transferred me some money
which is an interesting part of
cyberpunk is that
don't know if people are going to do
what they told you they were going to do
or if they're gonna betray you or if
they're just gonna run off or if maybe
he'd be thankful forever and I really
like that openness it means every
interaction requires more thought than I
feel like a lot of video games do I
don't know what the outcomes gonna be of
anything and I really like that so at
this point we're about up to scratch
with what we saw in the 2018 48 minute
walk through that CD Projekt RED have
posted which I can leave a link to below
what you talk to Dexter Shawn and then
you go to a Ripa talk from what I can
remember all of this is pretty much
exactly the same the one major change
here which we also have gameplay footage
of is instead of going directly to talk
to Meredith Stout who is romance Abul I
was told it's just very hard to romance
her she a [ __ ] I also don't know what
her preferences I did mention this in my
other video but the NPCs that are
amenable which I have Judy and Meredith
both confirmed I don't know what the
sexual orientation is and you are tied
to that sexual orientation which I
really like till I get sway it in a game
like fable what anyone you give a gift
to just immediately wants to marry you
these are real characters who have real
preferences but I digress
so instead of going directly to the
interaction with Meredith Stout which I
could have done in a bunch of different
ways which of course I am doing to get
Dex editions trust basically before I do
you know big mission for him I decided
to meet with another character who's a
strip club that is owned also by a
particular gang in the city I sadly
don't remember the name but I did talk
to the bartender so I can tell you that
the owner died they kept it in her name
in her honor had a good conversation
with him a lot of very just lifelike
conversations the character I spoke to
it's the girl with the blue hair you
guys have probably seen at this point
blue head girl is Evelyn pocket and
Evelyn basically has Intel to give me on
an upcoming heist which is where we
learn to brain-dead so she takes you
kind of into the back shooting and
Evelyn both explained that brain dancing
is usually used for pawn purposes by the
sounds of things and then we jump into
the brain death sequence
that you guys will have also seen
gameplay footage of I can put a chunk of
that in here anyway so part of this that
I don't believe you guys so footage of
was a second Brandon so the first one
that you did see is a tutorial the
second part is a brain dance recording
from a penthouse apartment that you have
to break into it's basically a heist is
being planned that that's a heist that
everyone is very much involved in
because there is this chip that everyone
really wants so you do that brain dance
it's much longer than a tutorial one for
sure and what you're ultimately trying
to find is something that would be of
the correct temperature you are looking
for some kind of storage unit that would
be able to house this chip that you know
has to be stored at this particular
temperature so you can listen to phone
calls and listen to the other side of
people's phone calls you can look at
tablets see what's on screens it's just
a lot of things that are going on in a
way that gives you a lot of context to
who lives here in this very very very
cool apartment so cool compared to the
stuff that you're generally seeing just
the regular night city well they tell
you that penthouse compared to these
apartment massive fast divided going on
there and they like I said really don't
shy away from that stuff so upon
completing that Brandon's I believe it
was upon completion I have a
conversation with Evelyn where she
implies that she wants to cut Dexter
DeSean out of the deal I didn't give her
any conclusive response I just kind of
said I'll think about it which I don't
think I ever had intention of doing but
another thing that I really like about
this game is much later on I got the
option to tell Dexter DeSean that she
had said that or I could not don't know
what the consequences are that comes up
so much in this game but I don't know
who I should tell what to or who I
should trust and I loved it so bright
Ned's completed I believe this is the
point where I went to my cyber psycho
it's basically a side quest that showed
up I believe somebody called it in to me
actually an austere assistants a psycho
psycho is someone who has psycho
psychosis he was basically enhanced
themselves to the extent that they've
kind of gone insane I like him they
exist in the world as sort of like mini
bosses that you can hunt down and get
cool stuff from sort of like Monster
Hunter so I drove to this guy which by
the way because I don't think I
mentioned this in my other video either
you can call you a car like roach which
I love you like press left on the d-pad
I think if you hold it you can choose
between different vehicles and which one
you want to call but if you just press
it one time
like in most recently used vehicle
whatever your default vehicle is and it
will come to you on the map like roach
like a self-driving car I thought that
was very cool so I call my car and I
Drive onto this bridge kill this guy
yeah it wasn't a terribly difficult
combat encounter he was the only one
that I really had to kill was a lot of
dodging and hiding behind things for
sure so I killed my cyber psycho and I
did encounter a couple of bugs around
here I didn't count a couple of bugs the
whole way through things floating order
you out of synch people's mouths not
moving but nothing major this one did
have a bug where it thought I was on the
phone and therefore I wasn't able to
interact with a quest thing that I
needed to interact with which is
obviously Obama but I did get cool
sniper rifle that let me shoot through
walls and cover which very glad I got
going into the next mission very cool
stuff so at this point I headed to the
interaction with Meredith Stout which
she will have also seen I didn't do
anything terribly different than accept
that I was very passive but I do also
want to say this is the only time in my
entire playthrough and I was told this
only happens at four or five times in
the entire game where I was locked into
looking at something the camera was
actually taken away from me for the
first time in the entire playthrough
which again yes so I go talk to Meredith
stop I'm by myself don't take anyone
with me Jackie's not on a corner with
the way that I did it I believe it is
also optional that you meet with her but
I do
she gives me a chip that she intends to
me to give to the gang to buy this bot
that I need from them and again this is
all gameplay you're probably seen but
I'm probably showing it right now over
this anyway because I chose to have tech
abilities from the jump i hack the chip
it did have a virus on it I get rid of
it so it is now just 10,000 credits good
to go io reconvene with Jackie we head
to the headquarters of where this deal
is supposed to be happening which is
basically a gang pretty much all of the
gameplay leading up to this is exactly
the same as what you've seen I play it
very very very cool in my negotiations
with one of those gang members and I
actually end up telling them because I
have the option to that the chip was
hacked so I'm playing this very
passively intentionally and because I
tell them that the chip was hacked my
outcome is very different to what
happens in the published gameplay the
gang does not decide to turn on me
instead I guess military edge asti's
they
someone has activated that chip and that
that virus did not go off because I
suppose they can still track it they
opened fire on the game so the building
starts to be overrun by Milotic which
means that gang me and Jackie are now
fighting Milotic together so the boss
fight that you see in that demo with the
big tanky guy this is actually very cool
didn't happen for me instead when I
walked into that room and I was
genuinely approaching this like a little
bit stealthy mostly running around like
killing they'll attack agents with a
shotgun covering where I could because I
really want to try that sniper rifle it
did take a little bit of figuring out
but also in a lot of instances I just
wanted to see what would happen if I
just sat back and watched if people
would kill each other and they
absolutely do so I get to that room
where you'd see the boss fight with the
mech and it's actually people from
Millett ech fighting that mech and I
just kind of sat there and watched
because of the way that I chose to
interact with the gang because of the
way that I chose to interact with
Meredith Stout because of the fact that
I chose to hack the chip I got one of
seven potential outcomes in that quest
where I didn't fight the gang they had
the boss fight that I should have had
which I really loved
can't think of many games that have done
things like that before very cool and
then I walk out of the building
milah tech is there but they're not
really on me because they're not after
me to be killed they are more on the
gang I think when I exit they don't
really try to shoot me Jackie and I are
able to leave and we have the book that
we want that approaches so we take our
boat we meet up with Dexter to Sean in
this bar area that was supposed to be
like where all the cool fixes go it's
been around for ages all of the the
coolest fixes have drinks named after
them and stuff but I'm sitting there
talking to Jackie and to the bartender
and waiting until eventually we get
summoned by Dexter and I think he's with
I believe the character's name is T
she's called us a few times leading up
to this point she's the one who hacked a
military ship we had a private booth and
we talked about the next steps which is
basically the heist that we had done the
brain dance for they give us these
militants I also have the option to tell
Dexter to Sean here if I want to that
Evelyn betrayed him I actually did
choose to tell him so they give us our
military efforts so we can get into that
building without it being odd basically
and they give us this very fancy
automate
car that can very much protect us on our
way there get this chip which I believe
is the chip that this game really
centers around it's the idea that
someone actually created immortality
there are ways to swap your body parts
out obviously but it seems like someone
has developed tech that would actually
steal your consciousness on a chip -
meaning that you could swap around to as
many different bodies as you like and
that was pretty much where the demo
ended I got in the car and then I think
I got like a little scissor real
cutscene of everything that was to come
very quick montage I couldn't tell you
all the images I'm off the impression
that if I had done that heist and got
into that building and found the chip
that it probably would have given me
Johnny Silva hand which is he on Reeves
character but I'm not sure that is as
much as I was allowed to play and that
is pretty much it for this gameplay talk
through everybody obviously this is like
very specific like here is what happened
in the thing if you want more of my
general impressions about you know how
combat or driving feel the qat that I
already did has that like I said I'm
going to have a sort of podcast type
video up on the first with three other
people who played it so we can talk
about just how different our experience
as well and yeah let me know if you want
me to do another Q&A where I can answer
in more detail very specific things I
feel like this video would have been
hours long if I gave you all of the
detail in the world but that is pretty
much it for me everyone I'm Alana Oh see
you guys next time